Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. hello welcome back to our uh french president special uh we've done de gaulle we've done pompadour we've done destang uh all of whom were on the right um and now we come to the first left-wing president françois mitraud who came to power in 1981. But, Dominic, he did not begin as a left-winger, did he? No, he didn't, actually. It's funny because actually Chirac, who succeeded him, began on the left.
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎回到我们的法国总统特别节目——我们讲过了戴高乐，讲过了蓬皮杜，讲过了德斯坦，他们都是右翼；现在我们迎来了第一位左翼总统弗朗索瓦·密特朗，他在1981年上台。但是，多米尼克，他一开始可不是左翼，对吧？没错，他确实不是。有趣的是，后来接替他的希拉克最初反而是从左翼开始的。
He was a communist. And Mitterrand began on the kind of conservative, nationalist, Catholic right in the 1930s. I mean, Mitterrand and Chirac are both, they are two immensely kind of vulpine feline cynical men who make british politicians i think looks like absolute paragons of principle um so so meet and wrong born in 1916 uh comes from a catholic conservative family in the southwest in the charlotte you were talking before the break about the war. I mean, Mitterrand has quite a dubious war.
他曾是一名共产党员。而密特朗在20世纪30年代则是从保守、民族主义的天主教右翼起家的。我的意思是，密特朗和希拉克都是那种极其狡猾、像猫一样精明、玩弄权术的人，我觉得这让英国政治家看起来简直就像品德高尚的楷模。所以，密特朗于1916年出生，来自西南部夏朗德的一个天主教保守派家庭。你在中场休息前谈到了战争。我是说，密特朗的战争经历相当可疑。
He does. He spends the first half basically working as a civil servant in the Vichy regime. He's a PAW, isn't he? He gets captured. He is. And he escapes, in inverted commas, and then, before you know it, is working in the Vichy government. Yeah.
确实如此。他把前半段基本上都用来维希政权当公务员。他是个战俘，对吧？他被俘了。是的。然后他逃跑了——加了引号的逃跑，接着没过多久，他就开始在维希政府工作了。是的。
And there's the definite whiff of something that doesn't entirely hang together there. But then he flees to london in 1943 and is involved with the resistance so he sort of i mean most people i think would say about me to rise he has a foot in both camps and actually you know what we could easily beat up on him about that but most french men and women had a foot in both camps one way or another i mean the lines were not the golden exactly clear well okay the gold in the 19th but apart from the goal and apart from a handful of people, most people are sort of treading a fine
这里面显然有一种说不通的猫腻。但后来他在1943年逃往伦敦，并参与了抵抗运动，所以他算得上是……我想大多数人都会对密特朗做出这样的评价：他脚踩两条船。其实，你知道吗，我们完全可以因此而痛斥他，但当时绝大多数法国人以这样或那样的方式都脚踩两条船，我的意思是，界限并不是那么绝对清晰。好吧，除了戴高乐……当然，除了戴高乐，还有少数人，大多数人其实都在走钢丝，
line between collaboration and resistance. But I just mentioned that because Mitterrand does kind of, you know, he moves to the left and he kind of makes a name for himself as someone who is the anti-de Gaulle. Yeah, that's right. Absolutely. So when de Gaulle came in in
在合作与抵抗之间寻求平衡。我之所以提到这一点，是因为密特朗确实……你知道的，他转向了左翼，并且作为反戴高乐的代表人物而树立了名声。是的，没错。完全正确。所以当戴高乐在1958年上台、
1958, re-does the constitution, sets up the Fifth Republic, Mitterrand is quite outspoken in opposing him. And Mitterrand is also the person who stands against him during De Gaulle's first kind of national sort of democratic presidential election.
重修宪法并建立第五共和国时，密特朗直言不讳地反对他。在戴高乐首次举行全国性的民主总统选举时，密特朗也是站出来与他竞选的人。
Do you see this, that Mitterrand was also accused at this point of faking an assassination attempt against himself? Yes, yes. The observatory affair very very weird and to go refuses to make political capital out of it on the grounds that mitra may end up becoming president and therefore yeah to do so would uh lower the dignity of the uh i saw that story and
你知道吗，密特朗当时还被指控自导自演了一场针对他自己的刺杀未遂事件？是的，是的。天文台事件，非常非常诡异。而戴高乐拒绝利用这一点来谋取政治资本，理由是密特朗最终可能会成为总统，因此，这样做会降低总统职位的尊严……我看到这个故事时，
i thought that sounds to me like a story that mitra was told himself to go wouldn't use that against me because he knew that one day i would be president of France. Well, no, because that would imply that Mitterrand was up to no good. So I don't think Mitterrand would have originated it. But did De Gaulle really say, one day that young man will be, I don't know, that sounds very kind of like Alfred the Great going to Rome to me? Well, absolutely. I mean, but it exemplifies De Gaulle's elevated sense of the presidency. Maybe. Ultimately, the standing of the presidency is greater than the political rivalry between left and right. Maybe. So I think it's a kind of paradigmatic story. Well, Mitterrand
心想这听起来就像是密特朗自己编造的传闻：“戴高乐不会用这个来对付我，因为他知道总有一天我会成为法国总统。”嗯，不对，因为那意味着密特朗在干坏事。所以我觉得这不可能是密特朗自己搞出来的。但戴高乐真的说过“总有一天那个年轻人会……”之类的话吗？听起来很像阿尔弗雷德大王去罗马的故事。完全是无稽之谈。不过，这体现了戴高乐对总统职位崇高的尊严感。也许吧。归根结底，总统职位的地位高于左右翼之间的政治竞争。也许吧。所以我觉得这是一个标准的传奇故事。好吧，密特朗
comes in in 1981, and he's been in French politics forever. And he's very good at, I think, playing the president. You know, I think that sort of Hollywood. The hauteur. Yeah, the hauteur. He, of course, has pretty good relations with Margaret Thatcher, contrary to what everyone thinks. He famously says she has the eyes of Killer Giller and the lips of Marilyn Monroe. He's a great pal of hers in the Falklands War.
在1981年上台，而他已经在法国政坛混了极其漫长的时间。我觉得他非常擅长扮演总统的角色。你知道的，那种好莱坞式的气场。高傲。对，那种高傲。当然，与所有人的想象相反，他和玛格丽特·撒切尔的关系其实相当不错。他曾有一句名言：“她有着卡利古拉的眼睛和玛丽莲·梦露的嘴唇。”在马岛战争期间，他是撒切尔的铁杆密友。
She handbags him in European summits and he doesn't really mind. He's got this sort of charming lounge lizard side that I think French presidents should have and actually generally do have. But he starts off incredibly to the left, doesn't he? Yeah, and then abandons that basically. And he kind of nationalises everything. And then he kind of gets forced into a corner by the men of Zurich.
她在欧洲峰会上用手提包“教训”他，他也并不怎么介意。他有着那种迷人的花花公子风范，我觉得法国总统就该有这种特质，而且他们通常也确实如此。但他一开始的立场极其左倾，对吧？是的，然后基本上就把这一套给抛弃了。他把所有东西都国有化了。然后他被“苏黎世的财阀们”逼入了绝境。
Basically, exactly, yeah. He has a thing called the 110 Propositions. So he has a wealth tax, and he's going to increase the minimum wage. He's going to nationalise lots of things. Very kind of Benite, to use a British term, programme. He comes in with that in 81, and by about 83, 84, he's abandoned that, and they have this thing called the turning towards rigor, which is actually masterminded by his finance minister, Jacques Delors,
基本上就是这样，没错。他有一个叫做“110条主张”的项目。所以他设立了财富税，打算提高最低工资。他要将许多产业国有化。用英国的一个词来形容，这是一个非常贝尼特式的纲领。他在1981年带着这套纲领上台，到了1983、1984年左右，他就把这些全抛弃了，他们推出了一个叫作“转向严厉财政”的政策，这实际上是由他的财政大臣雅克·德洛尔一手策划的，
later boss of the European Commission. Jacques Delors. Yeah, as the son. It's good to see you ventriloquizing the son, Tom. I think you should do that more often. We've had gotcha, so that's the other famous headline. So he sort of moves back towards the centre, which is quite a common thing, I think, for French presidents, that
也就是后来的欧盟委员会主席。雅克·德洛尔。是的，作为他的儿子……很高兴看到你借托姆之口来发出声音，托姆。我觉得你应该多来几次。我们刚才提到了“抓到了”，这也是另一个著名的头条新闻。所以他又回到了中间路线，我觉得这对于法国总统来说是一件很常见的事，那就是
over time, they start with great ambitions, whether on the right or the left, and over time, they basically end up being to survive, they become kind of technocrats. But it's more than that, isn't it? It's also that if you are truly to be president of all the French, you have to be in the centre. Yeah, there were lots of French friends because you you're playing a kind of monarchical role yeah
随着时间推移，他们一开始都抱有宏大的雄心壮志，无论是在右翼还是左翼，但随着时间推移，为了生存，他们最终基本上都变成了技术官僚。但不仅于此，对吧？还在于如果你真的想成为全体法国人的总统，你就必须居于中间立场。是的，有很多法国朋友……因为你要扮演一种类似君王的角色，是的，
that's so if you know if you're very party pre if you're very much of the right very much of left you it's harder to do that yeah i think that's true i think that's fair enough um but the other thing with me to wrong is that he he conforms to all the sort of stereotypes of french presidents so first of all he publishes false reports about his health and does so from the very beginning, I think. So it's still, I think, not entirely clear how long he was ill for. So how long he had prostate cancer, which eventually killed him. So how long he had that for during his presidency. He also gets up to various sort of dodgy things.
所以如果你立场太鲜明、太偏向右翼或太偏向左翼，你就很难做到这一点。是的，我觉得这很有道理，这很公正。不过，关于密特朗的另一件事是，他完全符合人们对法国总统的各种刻板印象。首先，他隐瞒甚至伪造了关于自己健康状况的报告，而且从一开始就这么做了，我想。所以，直到现在，我觉得大家仍然不是很清楚他到底生病多久了。也就是说，他患上前列腺癌（最终夺去他生命的病症）究竟有多久了。他在总统任期内隐瞒了多久。除此之外，他还搞出各种乱七八糟的勾当。
He wiretaps journalists. Bizarrely, Tom, did you see this? One of the people he wiretaps is the Bond girl, Carolol bouquet from for your eyes only why was he doing that i think she was going out with a journalist at the time or something right um but anyway we should do a podcast about bond girls to have been wiretapped yeah to clear that up yeah um but but also he um he builds i mean he he builds paris yes uh so the Pyramid in the Louvre and what else does he do? I can't remember. Yeah, he does lots of…
他监听记者。说来奇怪，托姆，你看到这个了吗？他监听的对象之一竟然是曾出演《最高机密》的邦女郎卡洛尔·布盖。他为什么要这么做？我想她当时正在和一个记者交往什么的。不管怎样，我们应该做一期关于被监听的邦女郎的播客，把这事弄清楚。不过，还有一件事……他建造了巴黎。是的，
Musée d'Orsay, all that kind of stuff. Right, he does lots of stuff in Paris. But also… Jacques Lange, his culture minister. He is his culture minister. Yeah. But also, there are two other things about Mitterrand that I think are entertaining. So one is the fact that he's obviously got the secret family life.
卢浮宫的金字塔，他建造了巴黎，还有别的吗？我记不清了。对，他在巴黎搞了很多建设。还有……雅克·朗格，他的文化部长。他就是文化部长。是的。除此之外，关于密特朗还有两件挺有意思的事。其中之一就是他显然有着秘密的家庭生活。
Now, this is absolutely extraordinary. Actually, at first you think, oh, it's actually quite a touching story, but then when you look into it, it's a really dodgy story. He has this relationship for 33 years with the Louvre's sculpture expert, a woman called Anne Pangeot, I think her name is. And you sort of think, oh, he's got this very French behavior. He's got this other family, and he's got a daughter with her and stuff. But actually, when I looked into it, they met, Tom. Did you see this? He was in his early 40s, and she was 14.
这绝对是非同寻常。起初你可能会觉得，哦，这其实是个挺感人的故事，但深入了解后，你会发现这是一个非常离谱的故事。他与卢浮宫的雕塑专家、一个名叫安娜·潘若的女性保持了长达33年的地下恋情。你会想，哦，他这真是很“法兰西”的行为，他有另一个家庭，还和她生了一个女儿什么的。但实际上，当我深入调查时发现，托姆，他们相遇时，
So French presidents and women of a very disproportionate age this is another thing because i get this they met because he her father played golf with him at the seaside and brought him back to the house afterwards for a drink or something and said oh i'd like to introduce my my my 14 year old daughter 14 year old barely teenage daughter they ended up having a 33 year relationship and having a daughter called Mazarin, who only basically emerged into the public spotlight in the 1990s when she was already in her 20s. So that side of things is… But he had a son as well, didn't he?
他已经四十出头，而她才14岁。所以法国总统和年龄极不对等的女性在一起，这也是个老毛病了。他们相识是因为她的父亲在海边和他一起打高尔夫球，事后把他带回家里喝了杯酒什么的，然后说：“哦，我想向你介绍一下我十四岁的女儿。”十四岁、刚刚进入青春期的女儿。他们最后维持了33年的恋情，并生下了一个名叫马萨林的女儿，这个女儿直到20世纪90年代她已经二十多岁时，才正式进入公众视野。所以，这方面的事情……但他还有一个儿子，对吧？
Yes, I can't… A Swedish journalist. That's right. He was called. He did indeed. Which is a very improbable name for the son of a French president. It's a sort of very Viking name, isn't it? Yeah, it is. It's actually under the northman but then there's also tom mitterrand's
是的，我想……一个瑞典女记者。没错。那个孩子的名字叫……他确实有一个儿子。对于法国总统的儿子来说，这是一个极其不可思议的名字。这是一种非常维京风格的名字，对吧？是的，确实如此。实际上来自诺曼人。但除此之外，还有托姆，关于密特朗
sort of you know mitterrand shuffling shuffling off this mortal coil so he leaves office in 1995 but he's already basically terminally ill and he dies on the 8th of january 1996 but before that he has a last meal yes have you Have you studied Peter Ron's last meal? I knew about this. As you'll know, I'm very keen on conservation. Yeah, on birds. And not killing endangered birds. So he has oysters and foie gras.
……也就是密特朗走完他的人生旅程。他在1995年卸任，但当时他其实已经身患绝症，并于1996年1月8日逝世。但在那之前，他享用了最后一顿大餐。是的。你研究过皮埃尔·罗恩（密特朗）的最后一餐吗？我知道这事。正如你所知，我对自然保护非常热衷。是的，对鸟类。并且坚决不杀害濒危鸟类。所以他吃了生蚝和鹅肝。
Foie gras already controversial in some quarters. And he has this great sort of French delicacy, an autolong bunting. You know these birds? These endangered birds. And the way they eat them, they force feed them first. That's very French culinary behavior. Then they drown the bird in Armagnac. I mean, they literally drown it, sort of Duke of Clarence style.
鹅肝在某些地方已经备受争议了。他还吃了一道极具法国特色的美食——圃鹀（ortolan bunting）。你知道这种鸟吗？这些濒危鸟类。他们吃它们的方式是，首先强行喂食它们。这非常符合法国人的烹饪习惯。然后把鸟淹死在雅马涅白兰地里。我的意思是，他们真的是把它淹死，有一种克拉伦斯公爵式的死法。
And then the way you eat it is the bird is roasted. You take the bird by its head. And you put a napkin over your head. Right, a napkin or a towel over your own head. You eat the bird whole, crunching all the bones. Then you have to spit out all the bones underneath your towel. And this is the most tremendous. It is apparently the most rapturous culinary experience.
接着烹饪的方式是把这只鸟烤熟。你抓着鸟的头部。把餐巾纸盖在你的头上。没错，把餐巾纸或毛巾盖在自己的头上。你整只鸟吃下去，把所有的骨头都嚼碎。然后你必须把所有的骨头从毛巾底下吐出来。这绝对是一场极其震撼的体验。据说这是最令人陶醉的美食体验。
Is it? Apparently. I think all the most rapturous culinary experience. Is it? Apparently. I think all the stuff about the bones puts me off for one thing. Eat an autolat and die, which is what Mitterrand did. Well, it is what he did. Because that was his last meal, wasn't it? I think the thing about putting a towel over your head, I mean, is that going to catch on? Surely not.
是吗？据说是这样的。不过我觉得光是处理骨头这事就让我有点退缩了。吃一只圃鹀然后死去，密特朗就是这么干的。嗯，他确实这么干了。因为那是他的最后一餐，对吧？我觉得把毛巾盖在头上的那个做法，这真的会流行起来吗？绝对不可能吧。
Supposedly that's because you can't. Some people claim that's because it intensifies the aroma and others say it's because you can't you know what you're doing is a sin and god can't see you doing it uh i think both of those are entirely plausible um yeah well i think i think we've summed up the key events of metron's presidency there absolutely yeah he eating birds soaked in armagnac. Hanging around with teenagers. He had two illogical children. And did he do anything else, Dominic?
据说那是为了……有些人声称这是为了增强香气，而另一些人则说是因为你知道你在做一件罪恶的事，上帝看不见你在这么做。我觉得这两种说法都完全合乎情理。嗯，好吧，我觉得我们已经总结了密特朗总统任期的主要事件。绝对是的。吃泡在雅马涅白兰地里的鸟。跟未成年人厮混。他有两个非婚生子女。多米尼克，他还做了别的吗？
I mean, he was very – he negotiated with Thatcher. He blew up the Rainbow Warrior. Yeah, he blew up the Rainbow Warrior. But he played a key role in the end of the Cold War. Yeah, German unification. German unification. Yeah. And he had a moving ceremony, didn't he, with Chancellor Kohl?
我的意思是，他非常……他与撒切尔进行了谈判。他炸沉了“彩虹勇士”号。对，他炸沉了“彩虹勇士”号。但他对冷战的结束发挥了关键作用。是的，德国统一。德国统一。是的。而且他和科尔总理举行了一场感人的仪式，对吧？
They held hands. They held hands. Yeah, very sweet. And stood in the rain together. Yes. As a symbol of Franco-German amateurism. Chancellor Kohl, I think, is a man who would eat a bird. But I don't think Chancellor Kohl was a man of such.
他们手拉着手。他们手拉着手。是的，非常温馨。一起站在雨中。是的。作为法德友好的象征。科尔总理，我觉得是一个会吃这种鸟的人。但我认为科尔总理不是那种……
Although Chancellor Kohl actually ended up in later life, as some listeners may remember, being sort of imprisoned by his – The evil nurse, didn't he? Yeah. So – Yeah. I'd rather have Mitterrand's fate, I think. It's all – I mean, the more you do this, British politics just looks – So tawdry.
尽管科尔总理在晚年的时候，正如一些听众可能还记得的那样，被他的——那个邪恶的护士给软禁了，不是吗？是的。所以——是的。我宁愿选择密特朗的命运。这真是……我的意思是，你了解得越多，英国政治看起来就越是——那么俗气。
No, I think it's incredibly sensible by comparison. Yeah, it looks – yes, it looks bourgeois, doesn't it? None of this happens to John Major. I mean, he's never eaten a bird with a towel over his head. Well, and talking of bad behaviour, the next president is none other than Jacques Chirac, who we mentioned earlier. And he's absolutely a constant, isn't he?
不，相比之下我觉得英国政治极其明智。是的，看起来——是的，看起来很资产阶级，不是吗？这种事绝对不会发生在约翰·梅杰身上。我的意思是，他从来没有一边把毛巾盖在头上一边吃过鸟。好吧，说到不良行为，下一位总统不是别人，正是我们刚才提到的雅克·希拉克。他绝对是个常青树，对吧？
I mean, he is there the whole way through. Yeah. Like a kind of bad smell. Chirac basically got involved with politics when he was about two or something. Yeah. And was constantly sort of plotting and being prime minister and... So he's prime minister twice. In the 70s.
我的意思是，他从头到尾都在政坛活跃。是的。就像某种恶臭一样挥之不去。希拉克差不多两岁左右就开始涉足政治了。是的。并且一直在密谋、担任总理……所以他当过两任总理。在70年代。
Yeah. And he falls out with Giscard. So he's prime minister under Giscard and then he's prime minister under... And Dmitri. And Dmitri. And that's the first example of cohabitation which you mentioned. Where you have people from different parties kind of once a prime minister and once the president yeah and in between that
是的。而且他和德斯坦闹翻了。所以他是德斯坦任内的总理，然后他又是在……密特朗任内的总理。和密特朗。这就是你刚才提到的“左右共治”的第一个例子。也就是由来自不同政党的人分别担任总理和总统。在那之后，
he was also mayor of paris well shirak is so so shirak is is too young to have been involved in the war he's born in 1932 his father was an aircraft company executive he was a communist as you said when he was young and and uh he went to sion's po he went to Sciences Po. He went to Ennard. So he's another Ennard. He's from those elite kind of training colleges for French politicians. He worked for Pompidou. Pompidou called him the bulldozer. But I think the thing about Chirac is Chirac.
他还担任过巴黎市长。希拉克……希拉克太年轻了，没有赶上二战，他出生于1932年。他的父亲是一家飞机公司的管理人员。正如你所说，他年轻时曾是个共产党员，并且他去了巴黎政治学院。他上了法国国家行政学院（ENA）。所以他又是另一个“埃纳人”。他出身于为法国政客提供培训的精英学院。他为蓬皮杜工作过。蓬皮杜叫他“推土机”。但我觉得希拉克最典型的特质就是希拉克本人。
In English? Le bulldozer. So he's le bulldozer. Yeah. The thing about Chirac is his absolute world-class cynicism, I think, isn't it? I mean, he is an absolutely shameless, graftor, completely corrupt kind of will, you know, is the way – well, he changes the constitution, doesn't he, so that the term of office will be five years rather than seven. Yeah. But also to kind of stiff the left, he makes it easier for the far right to participate in the electoral process. And the far right basically means Jean-Marie Le Pen, who we'll come to in due course.
在英语里怎么说？Le bulldozer（推土机）。所以他就是“推土机”。是的。希拉克最典型的特征是他那世界级的冷酷玩世不恭，对吧？我的意思是，他是一个极其无耻、贪婪、彻底腐败的家伙，你知道，他……好吧，他修改了宪法，把总统任期从七年缩短为五年。是的。但同时为了打压左翼，他也让极右翼更容易参与到选举进程中。极右翼指的就是让-玛丽·勒庞，我们稍后会谈到他。
And it's under Chirac that you have the kind of the development where Jean-Marie Le Pen makes it to the second round in the 2002 election. And so people vote for him. They say better to vote for the crook than the fascist. Yeah, better the crook than the fascist. He, and I think everyone, had been expecting that the man who had served as his prime minister, in a second experience of Cohabitation, Lionel Jospin, the socialist leader, would make it through.
正是在希拉克任内，出现了让-玛丽·勒庞闯入2002年大选第二轮的历史性发展。所以人们不得不投票给他。他们说“与其选法西斯，不如选个骗子”。是的，“与其选法西斯，不如选骗子”。他，以及所有人，原本都以为在第二次“左右共治”中担任他总理的莱昂内尔·若斯潘（社会党领袖）会闯入第二轮。
And I always adored Jospin because he looked exactly like a baby owl. Do you remember him? I do remember Jospin. Adorable little, imagine him falling out of a nest. He looked a bit like that guy, Jolien Morm. Didn't he? Yes, but more like an guy, Jolien Morm. Didn't he? Yes, but more like an owl than Jolien Morm. Okay, all right.
我一直都很崇拜若斯潘，因为他长得太像一只猫头鹰幼崽了。你还记得他吗？我当然记得若斯潘。可爱的小东西，想象一下他从鸟巢里掉下来的样子。他长得有点像那个家伙，于连·莫尔姆。不是吗？是的，不过比于连·莫尔姆更像猫头鹰。好吧，好吧。
Well, the two things about Chirac that I think are more... Obviously, he opposed Iraq. Yes, so he opposed Iraq, and he was very rude about British cooking. Cooking. He said only Finnish cooking was worse. And I think Finnish cooking is now very fashionable. So Chirac looks at all. It is, yeah.
关于希拉克的两件事，我觉得更有趣的是……显然，他反对伊拉克战争。是的，他反对伊拉克战争，而且他对英国烹饪非常粗鲁。烹饪。他说只有芬兰烹饪比英国更糟糕。不过我觉得现在芬兰烹饪非常时髦。所以希拉克看着这一切……确实挺时髦的。
But Chirac was colossally corrupt as mayor of Paris. He was mayor of Paris from 1977 to 1995. It was a new job. He did a bit of a kind of Boris Johnson. So he took this sort of this new job running a capital city, and he used it as a platform to advance his kind of national ambitions. But when he was running Paris, they had vote rigging, they had tons of kickbacks on public housing, lots of people had made up fictional jobs, sort of dozens of fictional jobs that
但希拉克在担任巴黎市长期间极其腐败。他从1977年到1995年担任巴黎市长。这是一个新职位。他有点像约翰逊那样的操作。他利用管理首都这个新平台，来推动自己的国家级政治野心。但在他主政巴黎期间，那里有选举舞弊，公共住房项目有大量回扣，许多人领着虚构职位的薪水，有一大堆虚假的职位，
actually were, you know, he was paying money to people in his party. He spent hundreds of thousands of euros on um gardening for himself and members of his own party and he spent would you believe 15 million euros a year tom on um on food which seems even if you're buying those birds yeah that's a lot of that's a lot of birds the auto layer well i i remember i was um i was writing rubicon duringicon during this period of Chirac's presidency where lawyers were kind of sniffing around his record. And there were all kinds of talks of bringing him to trial for corruption. And basically he wanted office in 2002 because it would continue to give him immunity. And that's very like Caesar in Gaul having to keep up his term of office so that he can't be brought to trial. And I remember that as a kind of a parallel.
实际上，他是在用公款资助他自己党派的人。他为自己和党内成员的园艺花费了数十万欧元，托姆，你敢相信吗，他每年花在食物上的钱高达1500万欧元，这哪怕是你去买那些鸟……是的，那得买多少鸟啊，那些圃鹀。好吧，我记得……我正是在希拉克总统任期的这段时期撰写《卢比孔河》的，当时律师们正在四处打听他的黑历史。有各种关于因腐败对他进行审判的传闻。基本上，他想要在2002年赢得大选，就是为了继续获得司法豁免权。这非常像高卢时期的恺萨，必须保住自己的任期，以免被推上法庭受审。我记得当时觉得这是一个很好的平行对比。
He's a very, very high class. In that side of his life, he's a very high class Silvio Berlusconi. Berlusconi was the same. Using political office to protect himself. He also has this, again, this sort of colourful sex life. So his wife, Bernadette, he and his wife called each other Vu instead of Chu. It's the ends of their lives.
他是一个极其高档的……在他生活的那个侧面，他简直就是高配版的西尔维奥·贝卢斯科尼。贝卢斯科尼也是这样，利用政治公职来保护自己。他同样有着丰富多彩的性生活。比如，他和他的妻子伯纳德，两人之间不用“你”（tu）称呼对方，而是用尊称“您”（vous）来称呼彼此，甚至到了晚年依然如此。
Very formal. Which you might think very formal, but also I think was a reflection of their slightly strained... Because she basically said after he died, you know, I stayed with him. I didn't really want to. He treated me very badly. His chauffeur would take him on all these assignations.
非常正式。你可能会觉得这很正式，但这也反映了他们之间有些紧张的关系……因为在他死后，她基本上说过：“我跟他在一起过，其实我并不想。他对我非常不好。”他的司机经常带他去赶各种私会。
And I've read two different versions of this. So one is that the chauffeur would call him Mr. 15 Minutes, shower included. Yes. And the other was that they called him Mr. 3 Minutes, shower included. But either way, anyway, it wasn't flattering. And, yes, so Ch sure it was his most spectacular um liaison was supposedly with the actress claudia cardinale who was in the leopard and once upon a time she starred with alan delon tom yeah so it all it all it all connects yeah it all
关于这个我读到过两种不同的说法。一种说法是司机称呼他为“15分钟先生，含淋浴”。是的。另一种说法是他们叫他“3分钟先生，含淋浴”。但不管怎样，这听起来都不怎么光彩。而且，是的，所以……希拉克最轰动的风流韵事据说是与女演员克劳迪娅·卡蒂娜有关，她曾出演过《豹》，而且曾经和阿兰·德龙合作过，托姆！所以这一切都是互相关联的，这一切都……
connects um but he must i mean he had achievements as well i think actually the funny thing is he looks like a french president when you see him at those they all do he has that kind of french president knows that destang had that meter or have that shirak had yeah and then sarkozy's who follows him lets aside down well shirak hated sarkozy because sarkozy had backed one of his rivals in the 1990s a guy called edouard ballardier but before we get into Sarkozy, let's quickly take a break for some publicité. See you in a sec. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
这一切都串联起来了。不过，他肯定也有过成就，我觉得有趣的是，当你在那些场合看到他时，他看起来确实像个法国总统。他们都这样。他拥有那种法国总统的气场，德斯坦有，密特朗有，希拉克也有。然后萨科齐接替了他，把这个标准给拉低了。好吧，希拉克恨萨科齐，因为萨科齐在20世纪90年代曾支持过他的一个政敌，一个叫爱德华·巴拉迪尔的人。不过在我们深入谈论萨科齐之前，先插播一条广告。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我们共同主持《娱乐其余》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将带你揭开娱乐产业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场演出门票的机会，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. So Dominic, Sarkozy succeeds chirac in 2007 uh sarkozy is obviously a different generation is 1955 and and actually i think the french president starts to become less interesting from this point because i think sarko is pretty interesting but sarko is is as a ludicrous character isn't yes but i mean he's nothing but a ludicrous and corrupt character. Well, so he wears platform heels. Yeah. I mean, he again has a kind of great, great marital record. Because he has three wives, doesn't he? Of whom the most famous is Carla Bruni. Yes.
欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。多米尼克，萨科齐在2007年接替了希拉克。萨科齐显然是不同世代的人，他出生于1955年。说实话，我觉得从这个时间点开始，法国总统变得没那么有趣了，虽然萨科齐其实挺有看头的，但萨科齐也是个荒唐的人物，不是吗？是的，我的意思是，他简直就是一个荒唐又腐败的角色。好吧，他穿着增高鞋。是的。而且他的婚姻史也同样相当丰富。因为他结过三次婚，对吧？其中最著名的就是卡拉·布吕尼。是的。
Yeah, that's right. Who's about three feet taller than he is. But he was also married to a model. Yeah. And he married someone else who's's and one of their sons is a hip-hop producer i saw that yeah it's it's so he kind of made his name his president bling bling partly as a sort of hardline interior minister so when they were high yeah he basically says um i think it's about 2005 he says i will clean up this scum. I will clean this scum off the streets with basically a pressure hose.
没错。她比他高出大概三英尺。而且他还娶过一个模特。是的，他还娶过其他人……并且他们的其中一个儿子是个嘻哈制作人。我看到过，是的。所以他有点打造了自己的“珠光宝气总统”人设，部分原因是他作为一个强硬派内政部长……当郊区骚乱发生时，
Yeah, so that's in the Bollywood, isn't it? And there were three boys and they get kind of electrocuted in a power station or something. That's right. A whole series of riots. And Sarkozy was the Home Minister at that time. That's right. And he said he wanted, he called them rakai, so scum. Yeah.
基本上是在2005年左右，他说：“我要把这些社会渣滓清理干净。”“我要用高压水枪把这些街头渣滓冲洗干净。”是的，那是针对贫民窟的骚乱，对吧？有三个男孩在一个变电站附近触电身亡了。没错。引发了一系列骚乱。萨科齐当时正是内政部长。没错。他说他想把他们称为“社会渣滓”（racaille）。是的。
And said that he wanted to apply a pressure hose to them um and and so that was actually i mean it got him lots of of blowback from the left but lots of votes but um yeah and and that of course is i guess a kind of growing theme in french politics is a kind of you know a kind of a hard right edge to narratives about race and particularly Islam. Yeah, I think that's true because Islam was not really an issue in French politics in the 1970s and 80s, even though there were lots of settlers from, I mean, when I say settlers, I mean there were lots of Pieds-Noirs and there were also lots of what the French would call Arabs because that's the word that they would often use that wasn't that wasn't a theme in the 70s and 80s it was anti-immigration theme but it wasn't
并说他想用高压水枪去对付他们。这确实招致了左翼的大量反弹，但也赢得了许多选票。不过，当然啦，我想这也是法国政治中一个不断增长的主题，那就是关于种族特别是伊斯兰教的叙事中，带有一种强烈的极右翼倾向。是的，我觉得确实如此，因为在20世纪70年代和80年代，伊斯兰教并不是法国政治中的真正议题，尽管当时有很多来自……我的意思是，当我说是移居者时，有很多黑脚（阿尔及利亚法裔），也有很多法国人所说的“阿拉伯人”，因为那是他们经常使用的词。但这在70年代和80年代并不是一个核心主题，当时主要是反移民议题，而不是
anti-islamist or islamic but that obviously became a much bigger issue from the 1990s well so so um sarkozy's interior minister during the um the decade after 9 11 yeah uh and actually kind of islamist attacks in france are probably the worst the worst of the continent worse in europe so that is kind of his his forging ground and it i think the reason why you say he's a he's a comical character is that an important part of his image is this kind of hard man pressure hosing the bonlieu all that kind of stuff and yet he's he's very small wears platform heels and can't quite carry it off yeah because the harban thing is posturing um political posturing i think the first thing he does when he i mean such sarcasm behavior sort of the first thing
反伊斯兰或针对伊斯兰教的议题。但从90年代开始，这显然成为了一个大得多的问题。所以，萨科齐在“9·11”事件之后的十年里担任内政部长。是的。事实上，法国发生的伊斯兰主义袭击可以说是欧洲大陆上最严重的、欧洲最惨重的。所以，这是他发迹的背景。我觉得你之所以说他是个滑稽的人物，是因为他的形象中有一个很重要的部分，那就是这个在郊区挥舞高压水枪的“硬汉”人设，然而他个子非常矮，穿着增高鞋，根本撑不起这种人设。是的，因为“郊区硬汉”这种姿态只是一种政治作秀。我觉得他当选后做的第一件事——萨科齐的行为总是如此——他当选总统后做的第一件事就是将自己的薪水翻倍，我想这完全符合人们对他的预期。很显然，他随后又卷入了更加骇人听闻的丑闻中，比如监听事件。他被指控从利比亚人、利比亚政府那里拿了5000万欧元。当你想到他曾经是那个伟大的——好吧，他和卡梅伦联合起来了，对吧？
you know the first thing he did when he became president was to double his own salary which i think is exactly what you would expect. And obviously he then is involved in the most, again, more hideous scandals, wiretapping. He's accused of taking 50 million euros from the Libyans, from the Libyan government, which, I mean, when you think that he was the great- Well, he joins with Cameron, doesn't he?
是的，他曾是攻击利比亚的主要策划者。是的，在萨科齐之后，紧接着是他的继任者，你基本上会得到两个失败的总统任期——两个没有扮演好高卢雄鸡角色、也没有以任何方式体现法国伟大精神的人。我是说，萨科齐是因为他的野心太赤裸裸了，而且在许多方面他除了纯粹的野心之外一无所有。完全同意，完全同意。然后他在2012年被一位自诩为“正常先生”的人所接替。这就是他用的词。但大多数人用来形容弗朗索瓦·奥朗德的词是“奶油焦糖布丁先生”（Monsieur Flamby）。Flamby是一种奶油焦糖布丁、蛋羹甜点。一晃一晃的，对吧？
Yeah, he was the great sort of progenitor of the attack on- On Libya. Yeah, and with Sarkozy and then with his success you basically get two failed presidencies two people who don't play the the ghoulish part and who don't represent in any way the grandeur of france i mean sarkozy because his ambition i think is too naked and because he is he is nothing but pure ambition in many ways agreed agreed and then he has succeeded in 2012 by a man who basically,
是的。而且他……尽管他有一个出色的名字。什么？你知道他大儿子的名字吗？托姆·奥朗德？威。（Oui.）托马·奥朗德。
he bills himself as Mr. Normal. That's the phrase he uses. But the phrase that most people use to describe François Hollande is Monsieur Flamby. And Flamby is kind of, that's like a kind of creme caramel, like a custard pudding. Kind of wobbles, doesn't it?
托马·奥朗德。是的，这是个极好的名字。但托姆，他让奥朗德这个家族稍微有些名誉扫地，对吧？不，我们要指出的是，他的名字拼写最后带有一个字母e。没错。因为否则的话，你说得对，
Yeah. And he's. Although he has an excellent name. What? And do you know the name of his eldest son? Tom Hollande? Oui. Thomas Hollande.
他就会玷污了“奥朗德”这个名字。因为他确实是一个不那么……我觉得他是所有法国总统中最无趣的一个，因为他曾是一名特殊人物，他是法国国家行政学院（ENA）的毕业生。他是密特朗的特别顾问，也是若斯潘的发言人。对了，他和萨戈内·罗亚尔结过婚。罗亚尔曾在2007年被萨科齐击败。
Thomas Hollande. Yeah, it's an excellent name. But Tom, he brings the Hollande dynasty into slight disrepute, doesn't he? No, so we point out that he has an E on the end of his name. Right. Because otherwise, you're right,
是的。而且她从某种程度上来说是一个更有趣、更有活力的政治人物。是的。直到目前为止我们还没提到的一点是，所有这些总统一直以来都是男性。塞戈莱娜·罗亚尔本该成为总统，但关于奥朗德……托姆，我查阅了2012年的一些竞选网站，如果你点击 francoisalonse.com 或 .fr 之类的网址，你知道现在上面是什么吗？那其实现在是一个出售空调设备的网站，这真说明了奥朗德的……因为当他成为总统时，
he would bring shame on the name of Hollande. Because he really is a less... He's, I think, the least interesting of all French presidents because he was a special, he was an anarch. He was a special advisor to Mitterrand, spokesman for Jospin. Well, and he's married to Céline Réal. Who had been beaten by Sarkozy in 2007.
我们谈到了关于“宏大雄心”的那套东西，结果他在一场可怕的暴风雨中举行了就职典礼，留下了极其滑稽的画面。无论如何，他看起来都不像个风度翩翩的家伙，但他当时被雨淋得透湿。我的意思是，他站在那里，带着一种非常类似克鲁瑟（Inspector Clouseau）式的尊严感，就好像有人……就好像上帝正往他头上倒一桶水。有点像于洛先生（Monsieur Hulot）。是的，确实有那种特质。
Yes. Yeah. And who, in a way, is kind of a much more interesting dynamic figure. Yeah. And something we haven't mentioned up till now is that all these presidents have been men yeah and singling royale was was supposed she was the one who was supposed to become president but to launch i had a look at on some campaign website tom from uh 2012 if you click on francois alonso.com or.fr or whatever do you know what it is it's actually now a website selling air conditioning units said it all about holland's because he became so when he became president
你知道他的支持率跌到了什么谷底吗？法国公众对他的评价？14%左右？不对。12%？4%。4%？天哪。
we talked this thing about the grandeur he was inaugurated during this terrible rainstorm and there are the most hilarious images of him he looks kind of an unprepossessing bloke anyway but he's absolutely drenched mean, he's standing there with this very Clouseau-like sort of sense of dignity, as though someone's basically, as though God is pouring a bucket of water over his head. It's kind of Monsieur Hulot. Yeah, it is that. Kind of quality.
4%。这是因为他……考虑到他本就不是个外表特别出众的人。不。我是说，希拉克、密特朗。
Do you know the nadir of his approval rating? The French public? 14% or something? No. 12%? 4%. 4%? Goodness.
我的意思是，你能看出他们有一种温文尔雅的气质。或许带着点世纪中期酒吧鸡尾酒酒廊的风格。他们就像鸡舍里的狐狸。是的。但非常、非常引人注目。他与罗亚尔分居了。
4%. Was that because he also, I mean, considering that he's not the most prepossessing of men. No. I mean, Chirac, Mitterrand.
是的。她把他赶出了家门，我想，是因为他和女记者瓦莱丽·特里耶韦莱鬼混在一起。然后他又把她给甩了。没错。和女演员朱莉·加耶在一起。是的。
I mean, you can see there's a kind of suavity. There may be the cocktail lounge of a mid-century bar. They are like foxes in a chicken coop. Yeah. But very, very kind of spectacular. He splits up with, a chicken coop. Yeah. But very, very kind of spectacular. He splits up from Royale.
而且他被拍到了一张著名的照片，骑着一辆小绵羊摩托车。一辆踏板摩托车。戴着一顶非常非常难看、毫无美感的头饰安全帽。但最绝的是，开踏板摩托车的那个人还让他中途停下来买几个牛角面包。你会觉得这简直可以由某个糟糕的70年代英国情景喜剧编剧给编写出来。你知道我最想听的是什么吗？我希望能听到一个与此类似的播客来恶搞英国首相。我是说，我确信他们看起来也会同样荒唐可笑。也许吧。
Yeah. She throws him out, I think, because he's been carrying on with a journalist, Valérie... Trier-Vaillé. Yeah. And then he dumps on her. He does. With an actress, Julie Gayet. Yeah.
我不知道。也许他们会把注意力集中在我们刚才讨论的那些真正至关重要的问题上。比如他们的私生活。除了他被雨淋湿之外，我们对奥朗德的政策还有什么可说的吗？没有，我的意思是，很显然奥朗德在20世纪2010年代的后半段当政，对于西方民主世界来说，这大概算是一个相当悲惨的时期吧。而且在他就职后不久，法国人基本上就认定他是个彻底完蛋的政客了。当然，他手下有一位年轻的工业部长，是从罗斯柴尔德银行挖来的，那就是埃马纽埃尔·马克龙。在2016年左右，奥朗德上台还没多久，马克龙就创立了自己的政党“前进党”（En Marche）。尽管马克龙那么年轻，而且坦率地说有点古怪，但他非常擅长扮演政坛角色。他以一种奥朗德和萨科齐都无法做到的方式展现了法国的伟大，你不觉得吗？嗯，我确实这么认为。而且我认为马克龙，尽管他——我的意思是，他埋葬了由奥朗德领导的、马克龙曾担任过其中部长的社会党。
And he was photographed, famously, wasn't he, on a kind of little moped. A scooter. A scooter, wearing a very, very unprepossessing crash helmet. But the great thing about that was that the guy who was driving the scooter, he made him stop off to buy some croissants. You sort of think this could be invented by some terrible 70s British sitcom writer. What know what I'd love to hear is an equivalent to this podcast doing the same to British prime ministers. I mean, I'm sure they'd seem equally risible. Maybe they would.
他也摧毁了戴高乐主义政党，因为戴高乐主义候选人弗朗索瓦·菲永不可避免地陷入了一场丑闻之中，涉及他的威尔士妻子彭妮。没错。据说她曾被雇为秘书，并为秘书服务领取了相当可观的薪水。
I don't know. Yeah. Maybe they'd concentrate on the same really crucial issues that we've been concentrating on. Their love life. Do we have anything to say about Hollande's policies beyond the fact that he got wet, got rained on? No, I mean, obviously Holland is in power in the second half of the 2010s a pretty wretched period i suppose you would say for the sort of western democratic world anyway um and and pretty soon after he's inaugurated i think the french make up their
所以从本质上讲，马克龙在某种程度上可以说是法国总统的精髓所在，因为我们在讨论总统超越政党政治的那种戴高乐式的理念。从某种意义上说，马克龙是所有总统中最具戴高乐色彩的一个，因为他实际上摧毁了政党体制。他埋葬了中右翼和中左翼政党，以至于现在法国政坛剩下的只有左翼和右翼这两个极端。是的，我觉得这很公平。因为马克龙会说：“我凌驾于这些琐碎的派系之争之上。我超越意识形态。我代表法国，代表法国的伟大。”他确实做到了。
minds he's a busted flush and of course he has this young industry minister who he's recruited from Rothschilds, who is Emmanuel Macron. In 2016, I think it is, so Hollande hasn't been there very long, Macron founds his own party, En Hollande, despite the fact that he's so young and frankly so strange, is brilliant at playing. He plays the grandeur of France in a way that Hollande and Sarkozy weren't capable of doing, don't you think? Well, I do. And I think that Macron, although he, I mean, he immolates the socialist party that had been led by Hollande and of yeah of which uh macron had been a minister he also emulates the goalless party because the goalless candidate francois fion gets caught up in a inevitably a scandal um involving his welsh wife penny that's right um who uh had been supposedly employed as a secretary and had been paid quite a lot for secretarial services.
是的，我也这么觉得。而且马克龙同样带有那种略显古怪的特质。哦，毫无疑问，我的意思是，他又是一个存在那种巨大年龄差的人。嗯，不过这对他的运作效果更好，因为这一次是他的妻子，她比他大24岁，我想是的。他们相识时，他在亚眠上学，对吧？她当时是他的戏剧老师。她当时39岁，已婚并育有子女。而他当时15岁。
So essentially, Macron, in a way, is the kind of the quintessence of a French president, because we're talking about the idea of the president rising above party politics in that kind of goalless sense. In a way, Macron is the most goalless president of all, because he actually destroys the party system. He has immolated the parties of the centre-right and the centre-left so that all that is left now in French politics are the two extremes of the left and the right. Yeah, I think that's fair. I think because Macron would say, I'm above such petty distinctions. I'm above ideology. I represent France, the grandeur of France. And he does, does yeah and I think probably I think
当然，你知道，他这一生基本上都不得不应对人们对此的嘲笑、冷嘲热讽等等。但事实上，托姆，还有一件更不可思议的事：他婚礼上的伴郎。是的。你看到这个了吗？是的。他婚礼上的伴郎。是的。你看到这个了吗？是的。他的伴郎出生于1924年。是的。所以当我计算一下时，他的伴郎比他年长了53岁。
but Macron also has that thing of being slightly strange oh I mean indisputably I mean he's an he's another one for the um the kind of the weird age gap well I mean it works better for him because this time it's it's his wife he's 24 years older I think yes he met they met when he was 15 and she was in Amiens isn't it and she at school she was his drama Yes. They met when he was 15. That's in Amiens, isn't it? At school. She was his drama teacher. She was 39 and married with children. He was 15.
换句话说，这意味着如果我的儿子以后也“效仿马克龙”，那么他的伴郎现在应该是63岁，而我儿子才10岁。是的，这挺难办的。但这种事不会发生，对吧？好吧，如果亚瑟（Arthur）未来的伴郎比我年长十岁以上，我会感到极其震惊的。我认为，马克龙很明显……我们一开始谈到了戴高乐写自己的故事，写自己15岁时击败德国人的事。那是一种非常丘吉尔式的做法。马克龙显然也有这种意识。我的意思是，有很多关于他在学校时就对别人说“我将成为法国总统”的传闻。
And, of course, you know, all his life he's basically had to cope with people laughing at that, sneering at it, whatever. But actually what is even more extraordinary, Tom, his best man at his wedding. Yeah. Did you see this? Yeah. His, his best man at his wedding. Yeah. Did you see this? Yeah. His best man was born in 1924. Yeah. So when I worked that, his best man is 53 years his senior.
而且，当然，你知道，他一辈子基本上都得应对别人对此的嘲笑、冷嘲热讽什么的。但实际上更让人难以置信的是，汤姆，他婚礼上的伴郎。对。你看到这个了吗？对。他，他婚礼上的伴郎。对。你看到这个了吗？对。他的伴郎出生于1924年。对。所以当我计算一下时，他的伴郎比他大53岁。
So in other words, that means that if my son does a macaron, his best man is currently 63 and he's 10. Yeah. That's quite hard. But that's not going to happen is it well i've got i would be absolutely astounded if that if what if if arthur's future best man is is more than a decade my senior um i think macron macron clearly we talked right at the beginning about de gaulle writing that story about himself general General de Gaulle beating the Germans when he was 15. It was a very sort of Churchillian thing to do. Macron clearly has that sense. I mean, there are lots of stories about him saying to people when he was at school, well, I'm going to be president of France.
换句话说，这意味着如果我的儿子马克龙（做伴郎），他现在的伴郎63岁，而他才10岁。对。这确实很难。但那不会发生，对吧？好吧，如果阿瑟未来的伴郎比我大十岁以上，我会感到极其震惊。嗯，我认为马克龙，马克龙显然——我们在一开始就谈到过戴高乐写过关于他自己的那个故事，关于戴高乐将军在15岁时击败德国人的事。这非常具有丘吉尔式的风格。马克龙显然有这种意识。我的意思是，有很多关于他在学校时对别人说“嗯，我将成为法国总统”的故事。
I'm going to lead France, all this kind of stuff. I think he is the embodiment of huge numbers of the trends that we've talked about in a kind of very, very self-conscious way. So he's been most recently in the news, aside from the election, for the role that he's played in essentially keeping lines of communication open with Putin. He wants to be the man at the end of that long table. He does, but he also wants to situate France midway between China, Russia, whatever, and the United States. So he said that NATO is brain dead. He's very keen on that. He's incredibly hostile to Britain. I mean, that's another kind of theme of, you know,
我要领导法国，所有这些乱七八糟的事情。我认为他是我们所讨论过的巨大趋势的集中体现，而且是以一种非常非常自觉的方式。所以除了选举之外，他最近频频登上新闻的原因，是他所扮演的角色——本质上是与普京保持沟通渠道的畅通。他想成为那张长桌尽头的那个人。他的确想，但他也想让法国处于中国、俄罗斯等国与美国之间的中间位置。所以他说北约已经脑死亡。他对此非常热衷。他对英国极其敌视。我的意思是，这也是那种主题之一，你知道的，
that's a kind of goalless tradition, I guess. He had a great grandfather from Bristol. Oh, really? Who'd fought in the First World War and who then cheated on his wife and ran off. That's why. That is a theory as to why he's but he also does relatively he also absolutely absolutely incarnates that thing that's to an anglo-saxon viewer of of treading that very fine line between being sort of impressive and being utterly ridiculous so wearing the hoodie
这算是一个无目标传统吧，我想。他的曾祖父来自布里斯托尔。哦，真的吗？曾参加过第一次世界大战，后来对妻子不忠并私奔了。这就是原因。这是一个关于为什么他会这样的理论，但他也相对地、绝对地、完完全全地体现了那种对盎格鲁-撒克逊观察者而言，游走于令人印象深刻与极其荒谬之间那条极细微界线的东西，比如穿着连帽衫
the power of french powers yeah that was very sweet i think he's much more impressive than ridiculous or posing in the last two days, Tom, showing off his bare chest. Have you seen this? His hairy chest. Yeah, but that's what the French do. I mean, what's his name? Jean-Claude Sarch didn't do that.
法国权力的力量，是的，那非常可爱。我认为他与其说是荒谬，不如说令人印象深刻得多，或者说他在过去两天里摆姿势，汤姆，展示他光秃秃的胸膛。你见过这个吗？他毛茸茸的胸膛。是的，但法国人就是那样。我的意思是，叫什么来着？让-克劳德·萨尔奇没有这样做。
Bernard-Henri Lévy does it. Does he? He's always showing off his chest. Okay. Yeah, no. At least you're not going in for ludicrous. We absolutely haven't gone in for ludicrous natural stereotypes in this podcast.
伯纳德-亨利·莱维会这么做。是吗？他总是炫耀自己的胸膛。好吧。是的，不。至少你没有陷入荒谬的境地。我们绝对没有在这个播客中陷入荒谬的自然刻板印象。
That's one thing we've very much i think macros is um i mean i think he's the most impressive current western leader by a long long way i i think well i mean the competition i don't think it's been i don't think it's been i don't think it's necessarily been good for france because i think that uh a healthy democratic system depends on healthy parties of the left and the right yeah testing one another and i think that that that he has essentially by annihilating that i think he's put french democracy in quite a quite kind of treacherous state quite an awkward state but i think that as a political leader as an embodiment of his nation i think he's in indisputably impressive uh he's charismatic. You know, his achievement in becoming president at the young age he has done. There's a definite trend here, Tom, because you love Tony Blair as well.
那是我们非常——我认为马克龙是……我的意思是，我认为他是当今西方世界长期以来最令人印象深刻的领导者。我——我认为，好吧，我的意思是竞争，我不认为这——我不认为这——我不认为这必然对法国有利，因为我认为一个健康的民主系统依赖于健康的左右翼政党，彼此对立检验。而我认为他基本上通过消灭这一切，把法国民主置于一种相当危险、相当尴尬的境地。但我认为，作为一个政治家，作为一个国家的化身，我认为他无可争议地令人印象深刻。他很有魅力。你知道的，他在如此年轻的年纪当上总统所取得的成就。这绝对是一个趋势，汤姆，因为你也爱托尼·布莱尔。
Yeah, I think he's a very Blair Wright figure. He is a very Blair Wright figure. I do like these kind of, yeah, charismatic. You like kind of… Charismatic centrists. Charismatic centrists who undo too many buttons, basically. Yeah, maybe. That's what you look for in a man.
是的，我认为他是一个非常布莱尔式的人物。他确实是一个非常布莱尔式的人物。我确实喜欢这种，是的，很有魅力。你喜欢这种……有魅力的中间派。有魅力的中间派，扣子基本上都不解好几个。是的，也许吧。这就是你在一个男人身上寻找的特质。
Well, don't you think he's impressive i mean he's more impressive than uh schultz or johnson or biden or but he's younger than biden um yeah i mean indisputably i think he could be his biden could be his best man good yes that's very true yeah he could be married to mrs biden that joe is his best friend yeah uh but you think i think he i mean i i agree it's not it's not a you know the current crop of western leaders aren't amazing but i think what's i suppose what i think is great politicians um or very successful politicians they have a profound consciousness of themselves being in the sort of the gaze of history and of playing a part.
好吧，难道你不觉得他令人印象深刻吗？我的意思是，他比朔尔茨、约翰逊、拜登或……但他比拜登年轻。嗯，我的意思是，毫无疑问，我认为他可以做——拜登可以做他的伴郎。好极了，是的，这非常真实。是的，他可以娶拜登夫人，乔是他的最好的朋友。是的。但你觉得，我——我的意思是，我同意，这不是一个——你知道，当前的西方领导人并不惊艳，但我认为——我想我认为伟大的政治家，或者非常成功的政治家，他们有着深刻的自我觉知，意识到自己正处于历史的目光注视之中，并在其中扮演着角色。
You know, they walk onto stage and they're conscious that all eyes are on them and they rise to that. I mean, I always think there's an amazing clip, actually, of Macron, because he was very young.
你知道的，他们走上舞台，意识到所有人的目光都聚焦在他们身上，他们不负众望。我的意思是，我总是觉得马克龙有一个惊人的视频片段，实际上，因为他当时非常年轻。
He was president at 39. And there's a clip of him soon after he becomes president. And he's going on a walkabout. And there's lots of, there's all crowds. And there's kids, teenagers. And one of them shouts at him as he walks past, ça va, Manu? You know, how's it going?
他39岁就当上了总统。有一个片段显示他当上总统不久后，他正在进行街头走访。周围有很多人，有大群的群众，还有孩子们、青少年。其中一个孩子在他走过时对大喊：Ça va, Manu？你知道的，最近怎么样？
And Macron stops with the cameras on him. And he goes back to this boy. And he says, basically, I'm not Manu to you. You call me Mr. President. And I thought, you know, in Britain, if a prime minister behaved like that, people would say, God, the prime minister, what a terrible arse. Well, John Prescott's the model for how to behave in a situation like that. You punch him.
而马克龙在摄像机对着他的情况下停了下来。他走向这个男孩，然后他说，基本上，对你来说我不是马努。你要叫我总统先生。我想，你知道，在英国，如果一个首相表现得那样，人们会说，天哪，这个首相，真是个讨厌的混蛋。好吧，约翰·普雷斯科特是在那种情况下如何行事的典范。你直接一拳打过去。
He's got a mullet, which is a display, but that's a reference to John Prescott. Tony Blair's deputy prime minister, he got hit by an egg yeah who punched a protester exactly but macron doing that macron has this tremendous sense of his of the grandeur of france i think that we talked about at the beginning um and i think that's i mean it's terrible to generate to degenerate international stereotypes as much as we've done but obviously that is a key element of the french presidency it's monarchical sense but we said right from the beginning that that is what you have to measure up to and that by that standards a macro i think is is probably yeah the most impressive president since uh since the goal and so by the time you listen to this you'll know whether he has obtained
他留着鲻鱼头，这是一种炫耀，但这指的是约翰·普雷斯科特。托尼·布莱尔的副首相，他被鸡蛋砸中了。是的，他打了抗议者，没错。但马克龙那样做，马克龙对法国的宏大有一种巨大的感知，我认为我们在一开始就讨论过。而我认为那是——贬低国际刻板印象就像我们做得这么多一样糟糕，但这显然是法国总统职位的一个核心要素，它具有君主制的意味。但我们从一开始就说过，这才是你必须去匹敌的标准，以此标准来看，马克龙我认为可能确实是自戴高乐以来最令人印象深刻的总统。所以当你听到这个时，你就会知道他是否获得了
re-election or not i think that even if he does i think france is in a bit of a mess because I imagine that the Marine Le Pen will have done better than she did in the previous time that these two contests of the election. Last time, I think, didn't she? And we haven't really talked about the Le Pens, but they are kind of a shadow lurking in the background because the French presidency was set up by de Gaulle who defined himself against the Vichy tradition. And in a way, the Le Pens embody that kind of the Vichy tradition. So there's a sense in which there is a political tradition there that is antithetical to de Gaulle and therefore perhaps to the entire idea of the presidency as it was formulated by de Gaulle.
连任。我认为即使他成功了，法国也陷入了一团糟，因为我猜玛丽娜·勒庞的表现会比这两人上一次竞选总统时更好。上次大选，我想，不是吗？我们还没有真正讨论过勒庞家族，但他们就像潜伏在背景中的阴影，因为法国总统职位是由戴高乐建立的，他将自己定义为与维希传统相对立的人。在某种程度上，勒庞家族体现了那种维希传统。因此，某种意义上，那里存在一种政治传统，它与戴高乐对立，因此也许也与戴高乐所构想的整个总统制理念对立。
I think that's fair because actually, I mean, actually that goes back even earlier than Vichy, Tom, because Jean-Marie Le Pen, Marie Le Pen's father, who basically founded her party and founded her movement, even though they've fallen out with each other, he was first involved in politics with a group that was associated with a group called Action Française, which was a far-right movement, ultra-Catholic, ultra-royalist,
我认为这很公平，因为实际上——我的意思是，实际上这甚至比维希还要早，汤姆，因为让-玛丽·勒庞，玛丽娜·勒庞的父亲，他基本上创立了她的政党和她的政治运动，尽管他们后来反目成仇，但他最初涉足政治时加入了一个与名为法兰西行动（Action Française）的组织相关的团体，这是一个极右翼运动，超天主教、超保皇派，
dating from the late 19th century, that was opposed really to the very idea of the republic. Yes, he's a monarchist, isn't he? In some ways, you could say that's what the Le Pen political movement represents. And also talking about the idea of being antithetical to what de Gaulle represents, Jean-Marie Le Pen was very, very opposed to de Gaulle's Algerian policy. Well, Jean-Marie Le Pen was very very opposed to Algeria de Gaulle's Algerian policy well Jean-Marie Le Pen was an intelligence officer in Algeria yeah and suppose you know there are rumors involved with torture or whatever so many people were so yeah there is a sort of people forget that before
可以追溯到19世纪末，它真正反对的是共和国这一概念本身。是的，他是个保皇派，不是吗？在某种程度上，你可以说这就是勒庞政治运动所代表的。而且说到与戴高乐所代表的东西相对立的理念，让-玛丽·勒庞非常非常反对戴高乐的阿尔及利亚政策。嗯，让-玛丽·勒庞非常非常反对阿尔及利亚——戴高乐的阿尔及利亚政策。好吧，让-玛丽·勒庞曾在阿尔及利亚担任情报军官。是的，而且你想，有传言说涉及酷刑或其他什么，很多人都是如此。所以，是的，人们忘记了在
the second world war French politics had been incredibly conflicted the very existence of the republic had been up for debate there had been talk of civil war in the 1930s and those kind of ruptures you know obviously they're very different now but the sort of i don't know i'm mixing my metaphors terribly but the kind of aftershocks of all that the the reverberations of it they're still there to this day and the le pen movement you know it's not just oh it's the left behind you know, it's not just, oh, it's the left behind, you know, people across that immigration or globalization or whatever. It has deeper roots, I think, that go back to the late 19th century, early 20th century France, the Dreyfus case and all this kind of stuff. Yes. And of course, someone who we haven't mentioned who definitely won't become president,
第二次世界大战之前，法国政治曾经历了难以置信的冲突，共和国的存在本身曾一度成为辩论的焦点，20世纪30年代甚至有过内战的传言。而这种断层，你知道的，虽然现在显然大不相同了，但某种——我不知道，我的比喻用得糟糕透顶——但这一切的余震，它的回响，直到今天依然存在。而勒庞运动，你知道的，不仅仅是“哦，这是被抛弃的人”，你知道的，不仅仅是“哦，这是被抛弃的人”，你知道的，那些受到移民或全球化冲击的人。我认为它有着更深的根源，可以追溯到19世纪末20世纪初的法国、德雷福斯事件以及诸如此类的事情。是的。当然，还有一个我们没有提到、且绝对不可能当选总统的人，
he's been knocked out, is Eric Zemmour, who, I mean, even though he's been knocked out is eric zamore who um i mean even though he's jewish has kind of chunted a little bit about um whether dreyfus was actually innocent yes extraordinary and has kind of chunted about whether vichy was really as bad as um people have said uh and marine le pen i mean we should say has um she has adopted a policy of uh trying to clear things up um so she has fallen out with her father he's she's expelled him from the uh from from from the party they've renamed um the front national the national front i can't remember what she's called it now but um changed the name um national rally i think it is something like that uh and she's always posing with her cats isn't she uh she she's a persian cat breeder is she alianzari would be
他已经被淘汰了，那就是埃里克·泽穆尔。我的意思是，尽管他被淘汰了——那是埃里克·泽穆尔，嗯，我的意思是，尽管他是犹太人，却一直在喋喋不休地质疑德雷福斯是否真的是无辜的。是的，太离谱了。并且还一直在喋喋不休地质疑维希是否真的像人们所说的那样糟糕。而玛丽娜·勒庞——我的意思是，我们应该说，她已经采取了一项试图澄清一切的政策。所以她和她的父亲闹翻了，她把他从党内开除了，他们把国民阵线（Front National）改名了——我不记得她现在把它叫什么了，但是——改了名字，我想叫“国民联盟”（National Rally）之类的，差不多吧。而且她总是和她的猫合影，对吧？她是个波斯猫繁育者，对吧？阿兰·扎里会对此
impressed by that baby yes um so uh she she has you know tried to tidy things up and i guess you could i mean one of the of course the other thing is that again seems very very striking actually looking the whole way back over these presidents is how very very right-wing france is yeah and we tend not to think of france as being right-wing i suppose because of the revolution yeah but you know the vast majority of these presidents have been on the right all of them except for um mitra and alond macron i mean he's clearly veered to the right i definitely to the right yes uh you could say about le pen although she's described as far right her policies you know her economic policies her social policies are very very uh left left wing well much more left wing than protectionist they're protectionist
印象深刻，宝贝，是的。所以，她确实（你知道的）试图把事情理清楚。我想你可以——我的意思是，另一个当然是，再次显得非常非常醒目的事实，其实纵观这些总统的历史，法国是何等的右翼。是的，我们往往不认为法国是右翼，我猜是因为大革命。是的，但你知道，绝大多数历任总统都是右翼，除了密特朗、奥朗德和马克龙之外，所有人都是。我的意思是，他显然已经明显向右转了，绝对向右转了，是的。你可以说关于勒庞，尽管她被描述为极右翼，但她的政策——你知道，她的经济政策、社会政策是非常非常——左翼的。哦，比这更左翼，是贸易保护主义的。它们是贸易保护主义的。
um and since you know that is the intriguing element in this election is that uh melancholy who's the kind of the french corbin um picked up you know he came third just behind uh marine le pen where will where will his votes go because it's not immediately obvious that that macron would be more appealing to them yeah i think it's a globalist liberal um you know it's a very good point you make tom about um french politics and i think people often get that wrong particularly in britain because in britain where france is kind of the other um i think particularly people on the liberal left have a fantasy image of France. They think it's all kind of sipping rosé wine and leafy gardens and wearing polo necks and talking about existentialism. But in reality, I mean, I can remember very vividly just to end on a kind of note of utter self-indulgence.
鉴于此，这次选举中引人入胜的因素是，梅朗雄，也就是法国的科尔宾式人物，获得了——他取得了第三名，仅次于玛丽娜·勒庞。他的选票会流向哪里？因为马克龙对他们来说是否更具吸引力并不显而易见。是的，我认为他是一个全球主义的自由派……你知道的，你关于法国政治的观点非常好，汤姆，我认为人们经常弄错这一点，特别是在英国。因为在英国，法国是某种“他者”，我认为特别是自由左翼人士对法国抱有一种幻想式的想象。他们以为那里到处都是在绿树成荫的花园里啜饮桃红葡萄酒、穿着高领毛衣、谈论存在主义。但实际上，我的意思是，为了以一种完全自我放纵的调子结束，我能清晰地记得
When I was a language assistant in France in the mid-1990s. I remember once in 1995 or 6, so there were the Le Pen sort of bandwagon was really underway, but also the arguments about Islam were really sort of kicking off. And I can remember at one point very foolishly thinking this would be a good idea to have a conversation about this with my kind of 17, 18-year-old students. And they lived in an affluent sort of town in the south of France. I assumed utterly naively that they would think just like I did and my contemporaries in England, because obviously I didn't know anybody in England who was on the kind of far right. And I mentioned Le Pen in this sort of dismissive way, or gosh, isn't it shocking that Jean-Marie Le Pen gets so much support.
当我在90年代中期在法国担任语言助教时。我记得在1995年或1996年的某个时候，勒庞的政治浪潮真正开始高涨，同时关于伊斯兰教的争论也真正爆发了。我记得有一次，非常愚蠢地认为和一个17、18岁的学生谈论这个会是个好主意。他们住在法国南部一个富裕的小镇上。我极其天真地以为他们的想法会和我以及我在英国的同龄人完全一样，因为显然我当时在英国不认识任何属于极右翼的人。我以这种不屑一顾的方式提到了勒庞，或者说，天哪，让-玛丽·勒庞获得这么多支持难道不是很令人震惊吗？
And I couldn't believe how many of these, you know, trendy, good-looking 17, 18-year-olds, you know, not at all left behind kind of people, thought Le Pen was tremendous. And actually the first thing they generally said was, well, he'll, you know, he'll clear up all the Arabs. They said that to you? Yeah. Oh, yeah.
而我简直不敢相信，这些时髦、长相俊俏的17、18岁的年轻人（完全不是那种被抛弃落后的人）中有那么多人觉得勒庞太棒了。事实上，他们通常说的第一句话是，嗯，他会把——你知道，他会把所有阿拉伯人都清理干净的。他们对你这么说的？是的。哦，是的。
Without the slightest sense of shame or in a way that I don't think a similar group of people in England. Or Scotland. By and large, the sense in England and Scotland is that people under the age, say, of 25 will identify with Jeremy Corbyn or with Nicola Sturgeon and see them as kind of progressive rifles. By the way, if you're Welsh, we haven't forgotten you. Yes, I don't know how. will identify with Jeremy Corbyn or with Nicola Sturgeon and see them as kind of progressive. By the way, if you're Welsh, we haven't forgotten you. Yes, I don't know how.
没有一丝羞耻感，而且我觉得英国的同龄人群体不会有这种反应。或者苏格兰。大体上，在英国和苏格兰，25岁以下的人会认同杰里米·科尔宾或尼古拉·斯特金，并认为他们是某种进步派。顺便说一句，如果你是威尔士人，我们没有忘记你。是的，我不知道怎么……会认同杰里米·科尔宾或尼古拉·斯特金，并认为他们是某种进步派。顺便说一句，如果你是威尔士人，我们没有忘记 you。是的，我不知道怎么……
Yeah, I guess, I mean, young Welsh voters likewise would vote for Labour, I guess. You know, they'd be anti-Tory. They'd be anti-Tory. The assumption of young people are more liberal, which doesn't work in France. I gather that the overwhelming majority of under-25s in France are voting Le Pen. Well, we shall see if that happens. But historically, Tom, the Front National has done well with young voters. And that sort of turns on its head what Anglo-Saxons, as it were, believe. It's not Le Front National anymore, is it?
是的，我想，我的意思是，年轻的威尔士选民同样也会投票给工党，我猜。他们会反保守党。他们会反保守党。年轻人更自由主义的假设，在法国行不通。我听说法国25岁以下的人绝大多数都在投票给勒庞。嗯，我们会看看这是否会发生。但从历史上看，汤姆，国民阵线在年轻选民中一直表现不错。这完全颠覆了盎格鲁-撒克逊人所相信的观念。它不再叫国民阵线了，对吧？
No, it's okay. It's not Le Front National, but it's basically the same. Right. Or is it? I mean, I don't know what you think about that so there is there is debate about that yeah about how how much it's changed okay no extent le pen fee would be i mean she's definitely a different order of politician to her father who was an incredibly sinister figure but the lineage you can't deny the lineage i do yeah um yes well maybe uh she's president now and we're talking about the new president but i don't think she she will be so um but and and that also is a kind of interest just to return to something i mentioned earlier the how masculine the french
不，没关系。它不再叫国民阵线了，但基本上是一回事。对的。或者真的是这样吗？我的意思是，我不知道你对此怎么看。所以对此存在争议，是的，关于它改变了多少。好吧，在某种程度上，勒庞夫人会是——我的意思是，她绝对是一个与她父亲截然不同的政治家，她的父亲是一个极其阴险的人物，但这种血脉，你无法否认这种血脉。我确实觉得……是的，好吧，也许她现在是总统了，我们在谈论新总统，但我认为她不会——所以，而且这也是一种有趣的现象——仅仅回到我之前提到的那一点——法国总统职位一直是多么的男性化。
presidency has always been yeah yeah um very true contrast there could i just also mention one other intriguing detail about the french president gone he is also the co-prince of andorra yes he is that's a great thing isn't it again it kind of unsettles our sense of i think the french republicanism i think he should make more of that i would make more of that if i was macron does i think macron is quite keen on the whole Prince of Andorra. I mean, Sarkozy looks like the Prince of Andorra. Yes, he does. He does.
是的，非常真实的对比。我能否再提一个关于法国总统的迷人细节？请说。他同时也是安道尔的共治亲王。是的，他确实是。这不是很棒吗？同样，它颠覆了我们对法国共和主义的认知。我认为他应该更多地利用这一点。如果我是马克龙，我会更多地利用这一点。我认为马克龙对安道尔亲王这个头衔相当热衷。我的意思是，萨科齐看起来就像安道尔亲王。是的，他确实像。他确实像。
Well, he's at home with the tag, Sarkozy. Have you seen this? He's got a suspended sentence for corruption. So he's got permission to spend it at home with an electronic tag. With Carla. Yeah, and Carla. And Chirac had a suspended sentence as well. It basically comes with the massive salary.
好吧，他对这个电子脚镣习以为常，萨科齐。你见过这个吗？他因腐败被判缓刑。所以他获得了许可，可以戴着电子脚镣在家服刑。和卡拉在一起。是的，还有卡拉。希拉克也曾被判缓刑。这基本上是和巨额薪水一起来的。
Yeah. Anyway, on that note. This has been an incredibly nuanced. A fair, reasonable, nuanced balance. A fair, reasonable, nuanced balance. And not in any way Anglo-Saxon take on the French presidency. Hope you've enjoyed it. Hope it complements whatever the result of the
好吧，就此而言。这是一个极其细致入微的视角。公平、合理、细致入微且平衡。公平、合理、细致入微且平衡。而且绝不是那种盎格鲁-撒克逊式的法国总统视角。希望你们喜欢。希望它能与无论什么结果的选举结果相辅相成。
election is. And we will see you soon. Au revoir. Au revoir. A la prochaine. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
我们很快就会再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听独家节目、抢先体验、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及优先购买现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。